The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Today is--
it's not exactly a
midpoint of the course,
but it is a transition
lecture between
these macro financial models
with micro underpinnings.
Today we're going to go
through the measurement,
and then in subsequent
lectures, focus on testing
for the micro underpinnings.
I mean, everything is
connected to everything else.
There's a quote--
I don't know, many of you
may be familiar with it.
It's really quite good.
Lord Kelvin.
In physical science,
the first essential step
in the direction of
learning any subject
is define the principles
of numerical reckoning
and practicable
methods for measuring
some quality connected with it.
I often say that
you can measure--
when you can measure what you're
speaking about and express it
in numbers, you know
something about it,
but when you cannot measure
it, you cannot express it
in numbers, your knowledge is
of a meager and unsatisfactory
kind.
It may be the
beginning of knowledge,
but you have scarcely
in your thoughts
advanced to the
stage of science,
whatever that matter may be.
So of course, today we're going
to talk about measurement,
and this is not an
economics quote.
This is a little more related
to both economics and impact
evaluation.
It's Bill Gates.
He's talking about
the steam engine.
In his book I think he must have
read on the most powerful idea
in the world, which is
about measuring the energy
output of engines with
this my micrometer.
The point-- he's
quoting Mr. Rosen--
is to see incremental
design changes
that led to improvement--
mainly what you want, higher
power and less consumption
of the coal.
And it was this interaction
between experimenting, trying
things, measuring
precisely given the goal
and then innovating
some more that
led to this high-powered steam
engine which revolutionized
the world, essentially.
So he's saying he's
struck how important it
is to measure-- to improve
the human condition
and how incredible the progress
could be if you set a goal
and measure it.
But then he goes on
to say that he is also
amazed how little
this is actually done
and how hard it is to
do it to get it right.
He gives an example
of foreign aid,
just measuring the dollars,
say, that flow rather than
the underlying impact
that it may or may not
have on household business
or country welfare.
So the type of measurements
that are needed or those that
allow us to assess
performance and gauge impact.
So this is the end of
what Bill Gates was saying
and the rest is
something I want to say.
Measurement is
tricky in the sense
that he's really not saying
just go out and measure
anything you want to
consistent with the goal.
For a while the Gates Foundation
was promoting savings accounts,
having poor people have
access to savings account
as a kind of panacea,
and indeed, wanted
to measure the
number of households
out there now who have
them and track improvement.
And there's a new world survey
done by the Gallup Foundation--
Gallup people who do
the polls, actually,
have survey
techniques worldwide.
But of course, from
our perspective,
just having a savings account
may not accomplish much.
It's not a kind of
measurement that's really
assessing the impact on people.
You'd like to know what impact
it's having on welfare--
that is to say on
actually using it
or better ability to smooth
consumption or finance
investments and so on.
Well fortunately
in economics, we
have one set of measurement
tools that are common,
and they're also consistent
with the theme of the lectures--
namely there is measurement
at the individual household
level that's also
consistent with measurement
of the flow of funds across
countries and everything
in between.
And what I'm going to
try to go through today
but here's a quick summary of
it is what these tools are.
Basically you start with
the financial accounts
for a household or a firm.
So that would be the balance
sheet, the income statement,
and the statement of cash flow.
You may associate that language
with corporate financial
accounting and wonder
perhaps about its relevance,
but they are the
benchmark standards
and they can be applied to
households and especially
to households running
businesses, which
is the typical enterprise
in developing countries.
So I'll show you in a moment
exactly how this can be done.
What use can you
make of these things?
Again, I'm going to try to
buttress my case that it's not
just measurement for
the sake of measurement,
but actually that you can
use these measurements.
So in this case, we'll
draw a distinction between
productivity and the return
on assets versus liquidity,
some distinction you could
not make if you were not
clear-headed as in applying
these financial accounts--
or at least it would be
quite easy to make mistakes.
And show how-- where
wealth is coming from
and how wealth
changes over time.
At the household level that
gets you into poverty dynamics,
you can start thinking about the
mechanics that underlie changes
in inequality.
And again, in an
application, take a look
at how households are making
a distinction, apparently,
between savings rates
and productivity
in terms of what they do
in their own investment.
I think you've seen in
the recitation section
sort of a precursor of
this in terms of the Thai
data and some case studies.
So in some sense, we're going
to go back to the basics
and talk about the
financial accounts,
but at least you have
a motivation already
for what households are doing.
Then we can aggregate
up from households--
say all households in a
village and create something
like the national
income accounts,
except they're not at
the national level,
they're village income accounts.
But we have the standard savings
and investment, GDP numbers,
and indeed, we get balance
of payments at the village
level or regional
level just so you
can see what's going on within
the country, not just of
the country relative to other--
and again, you've seen this
come up in the lectures--
China, provincial-level
China, at the national level
relative to the
rest of the world,
flows across sectors that
differ in obstacles to trade.
And finally, we'll get to the
flow of funds accounting, which
I like to think of
as the nuts and bolts
of the financial system
actually measured.
So you don't just
have to imagine
what's going on in
the country over time
in response to shocks,
you can actually
see it in the measurement.
So first paper up.
Not going to work?
Let's not cut off too
much, maybe it's all right.
Is to create-- well, I'm
just not fast enough.
Create the balance
sheet, income statement,
and statement of cash
flow for these households
in order to make the
distinction between productivity
and liquidity.
So this is a quote from
Deaton that I ask often show.
The only way to
obtain these measures
is by imposing an
accounting framework
on the data, painstakingly
construct estimates
from myriad responses
to questions
about the specific components
that contribute to the total.
So actually, there's
a computer code
that's you know 18 to 20
pages single-line code,
and it operates
on the Thai data.
It, of course, searches
over all the questions
in the questionnaire
in order to be
able to extract the
key variables that
are needed line
by line to create
these financial accounts.
We didn't begin with
the financial accounts.
I wish we had, because
then certain instances,
it would have helped
us measure better.
This was something
we came to afterwards
when we were just struggling
with a simple idea
of what do we really
mean by income?
Something very basic.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] more
like 100 page, you think.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's a lot.
AUDIENCE: And the way that
you look at it is initial.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
Version 1, version 2.
OK.
So what are the
problems when you
have these high frequency
monthly data or to some degree
even annual data?
There is a difference
in timing between, say,
when inputs are purchased and
when their outputs are sold.
If you think about farmers,
they only sell at harvest time
and they're using
inputs along the way.
It's true for businesses, too,
who don't sell instantaneously.
They have to acquire inputs
to produce something or buy
goods for inventory to stock,
and then subsequently sell.
We are worried about
liquidity, on the other hand.
So since smoothing
of consumption,
protection of
investment from cash
flow, financing a
budget deficits.
So we want to make
distinction between cash flow
in terms of liquidity and kind
of the overall performance.
The key idea with performance
is an accrual notion
of accounting, which
is simple to say--
mainly do not book
or subtract expenses
until the output is sold.
It's the idea of
corporate finance--
you have projects,
not occupations.
You buy assets.
You have an idea, you need to
fund it, you buy equipment,
and you don't expect
a return right away.
So for the short-run, you
have lots of negative profits,
but it's just a
cash outflow, so you
wait till you can get
the big picture, which
is when you get the revenue then
you subtract off the inputs.
But financing the
inputs along the way,
that's a liquidity issue.
And indeed, if
you're running out,
you may as not invest even
though your underlying project
or idea is quite successful.
So we go to the
financial accounts.
Now viewing households as firms,
we have to draw some parallels.
Assets are kind of easy to think
about both on the household
side and on the firm side.
Households have debt just
like firms have liabilities,
so those are straightforward
parallel concepts.
When you think
about wealth, wealth
is really net worth
on the household side.
The language for firms
is something like equity.
It's the amount of the owners'
investment in the enterprise
that's built up over
time that is not
as different from the fact
that some of the equipment
gets owned by
outsiders who financed
the project by lending.
What is the sources
of this wealth?
Well basically savings,
like retained earnings.
Savings for households, retained
earnings for businesses.
That part of the profits that
you put back into the business.
But also potentially
contributed capital
which I'll come to in a minute.
This is this may strike you
as odd at first, I'm not sure.
Consumption on
the household side
is the same as dividends
on the firm side.
So the consumption
we think we know,
but dividends is
like a firm paying
either the inside owners
or outside investors part
of the return stream.
So that stuff isn't going
into the firm anymore,
it's not retained earnings.
It's kind of the fruit
that you get to enjoy.
This is also a bit of a
stretch and can be problematic.
Incoming gifts on
the household side,
what do we do with them
in the financial accounts?
Gifts aren't really
income in some sense--
in the corporate
financial sense.
Because income is a
return stream of projects,
but gifts, that's just
something somebody gave you.
Well, so we ended up thinking
about gifts as financing.
So the idea is, someone
gives you a gift,
you have some implicit
idea of reciprocity.
So they're in effect
helping your enterprise,
they're investing
in your enterprise
even though the contract
may not be nearly as formal
as, say, an equity arrangement.
And finally, the household
budget constraint
is like the firm
cash flow constraint.
So again, we can
therefore distinguish
assets versus wealth.
Note how easy it would be
to make a mistake there.
Isn't that the same thing?
No.
Remember, the liabilities
get subtracted from assets
to create, quote,
wealth or net worth.
Accrual versus cash flow
I've said often enough.
Savings as a budget
surplus as in cash flow--
so you had more coming in in
revenue than you had outflows
in terms of expenses versus a
different notion of savings,
and that's savings as in
wealth accumulation, that's
where do you put the increasing
wealth that you're acquiring?
That's more like a
portfolio problem.
And therefore, we
need to distinguish
liquidity management
from asset management.
So quick review.
By the way, I'm really
going to struggle today
to make sure you don't just
sort of pass out on me.
Because accounting
has a reputation
as being really
boring, and it is true
that it gets more
and more tedious.
And so you kind
of like tune out,
like OK, I'll tolerate today.
But no, you'll
discover that when
you start doing your research,
whether it's looking at data
from surveys or gathering
data or trying to do--
and then you'll come back and
you'll be much more interested
in these things.
So the spirit with which I give
the lecture today is not the
bore you with the details,
even though at times it
will be tempting, because once
you've invested in this stuff,
you want to share
that knowledge.
But rather, to give you a
reader's guide or viewer's
guide of what the
key concepts are
and how things fit together.
So that latter thing is what
I want you to take away.
So here is a typical
balance sheet.
You've got assets and
you've got liabilities.
The bottom line
has to be the same.
Now how does that happen?
Well, you really
subtract liabilities
off from the assets, and
hopefully assets are larger,
so the residual is basically
equity or net worth, OK?
And then this is
just an enumeration
of different kinds
of assets, which
include financial and
trade credit and so on as
well as if-- lending as well
as your real physical fixed
assets, and liabilities are
kind of obvious, and so on.
So now let's get
into some cases here.
The Living Standards
Measurement Survey
makes a mistake if you want
to think of it that way.
They ask about inputs used over
a specified cropping season
and the amount spent.
And implicitly
they're equating them,
but they don't have to
be equal to each other.
For one thing, you could be
using inputs in your farm
that you acquired previously--
especially with monthly data,
it's likely you have some
kind of input inventory.
And for that matter,
you could spend money
and buy inputs but not
actually put them on the field.
And the same thing happens on
the output side, essentially.
What do we do?
Fortunately in the Thai
survey, we actually
keep track of both
inputs required
since the previous
interview as well as
the actual use, both value
and quantity of inputs.
So we have this input
inventory account.
And revenues I say here,
but don't dwell on it.
So what do you do when
you have the output?
Well, you could store
it or you could sell it
or you could eat it.
So you kind of have to
create an output account.
We act as if output is sold
at the time of harvest just
to put an accurate value on
it, but when, in fact, they
don't sell all of it or they
eat some and store some,
then we create another sort
of output inventory account.
So in high frequency data,
this sort of inventory
that your mind might
glaze over when
you look at a
financial statement,
inventory may be a really
key smoothing device.
And at the risk of
getting carried away,
there's something called
work-in-progress inventory,
and that happens when
you're using this accrual
notion of accounting
where you don't
want to subtract something
off as an expense yet.
If you don't subtract
it off as an expense,
then it's not on the
income statement.
Well where the heck is it?
Well basically,
you act like you've
created an inventory
of something,
like buying an asset.
So all the fertilizer that
you've put on the land
and all of that stuff
in the accrual notion
is work-in-progress inventory,
it's producing the crop.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So how do you--
literally-- so how
do you kind of--
so I'm assuming
that in your survey
you ask kind of a
simpler question,
like just count
assets and name--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --expenses and what--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: --like that.
How can you be sure that
your classification kind of
is what it is and it's in
the mind of the households?
So like I understand sort of
the asset versus wealth thing
and so on, but when you go into
this like inventories and stuff
like that, how--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We create that.
We don't ask the
household what they're
a work-in-progress inventory is.
We have that as a
conceptual category
as measured from
other variables,
like what did they buy,
not yet put on the land.
AUDIENCE: Would you think
it's interesting to go
see whether that maps
in into some sort of--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --way--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So
Chris Woodruff had done--
the inventory thing is the
hardest thing to get right.
And in fact, when
you think about it,
you buy maybe
inputs at one price
and you sell them in another.
So you can have--
or-- so you can have
capital gains and losses
on the inventory account.
AUDIENCE: Yeah--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
And-- and so yeah.
So what Chris has
done is actually--
he wrote a paper called--
and we take the
opposite point of view,
but his is, how is
the sausage made?
Or don't ask what's
in the sausage.
So he just asks households
basically what their income is,
and the view there is
that somehow they're
going to do better than asking
all these detailed questions.
We think it's better to
ask the detailed questions
and then construct the income,
but you can certainly--
and we didn't do enough of this.
So yes.
You should compare the answers
of the households to so--
and do the households have
in mind some liquidity notion
of income or do they have
in mind some sort of rate
of return calculation when you
ask them what their income is
in a given year?
AUDIENCE: Maybe even
like at an earlier stage.
So I think that in the
whole boredom of accounting,
there is some--
what I remember as
more interesting stuff.
It's like, everything that goes
on those statements you can--
it's either market
value, cost value.
So there's all sorts of--
and you can get all
sorts of numbers
depending on how
you value things.
So my question would be
in those in these settings
where I would
assume there's even
measurement error in
prices and everything else,
like how does that
all come together?
And how do you think noise--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So
I'm going to take you--
yeah.
So I'll take you through
a paper we wrote.
I'm going to formalize the
notion of rate of return
on assets, and
then I'll show you
one slide where we
did a lot of what--
the great virtue of
having all the data
is we could do these
experiments, say, what
if we didn't count something
we actually measured,
or what if we know
change categories
and put it in one
place and the other?
So actually rank-ordered
the three things
that matter most to
measuring productivity
so that we and especially
other researchers
might be able to do better.
Or not have to worry about
all the details on everything,
that's more to the point.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what do you
do with households that
also are running a business?
Do you ask them only about
household inventories
or the equivalent?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No, we
don't separate it at all.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So we treat
it as an integrated unit.
And again, my view of it is,
households don't necessarily
make that separation.
So we asked them
what is the profit
from running the business?
You're asking them
mentally to to separate out
all these things, to have
some money from wage earning
and so on.
So we prefer to
measure everything--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes?
AUDIENCE: --quick follow-up
on [INAUDIBLE] question.
In this sense in
which households
that are also a
business or just treated
as a business and
consumption decisions
are treated as a
unitary things--
really this notion of some sort
of corporate thing going on,
how do you then go into--
have you thought of--
do you think it would be
interesting to like integrate
that with household
decision-making modeling that
also treats the household
as a corporate firm?
So the idea of transaction
costs within the households,
how like-- or the household then
is still a unitary thing which
maybe doesn't make much sense
because there should be--
there could be like the
woman is a manager of the--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So there are two
things going on here.
One is household non-business
activities and the other
is business activities,
and we prefer
to try to measure all of that
and have an integrated account.
Now in terms of--
a household is collection
of individuals,
could we do the accounting
at the individual level?
In some instances,
we're painfully aware
that this notion we have
that this group of people
is a household and is a
unit is stretching things,
and yet that was our
starting point, to have
a household-level survey.
For one thing, the demands
even in the measurement
of interviewing everybody
individually is horrendous.
Also, you know some
assets are held jointly
or people may
disagree about who's
got the real claims on them.
I mean, that said, there
are instances clearly
where the husband may be
hiding some of his income
or the young teenager
still living at home
actually have some earnings
in his or her bank account
and that's kind of not
commingled with the rest
of the family budget, and those
are real, real problems for us.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I think
to be fair to some extent,
you can make that criticism of
corporate accounting as well,
that maybe they're like--
they're not acting as a unit or
there are people doing things
that you can't see
in the accounts
and that just looking
at a firm statement
would be different if you
would like to sit down
with every member
of a corporate firm
and ask, what did you
spend money on this month?
Where did you-- all
this sort of stuff.
So I feel like to some
extent, the criticisms here
are criticisms that apply to the
general framework of accounting
and not to the household
problem specifically.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, there's
is some stuff I took out,
otherwise the lecture
would be even longer, which
is, do these problems-- you have
a conglomerate which consists
of different firms, and
there are issues there
about the flows from
one to the other.
Here, you could treat a
marriage, for example,
as a merger of two firms, and
there is development literature
like that.
Mark Rosenzweig
has written I think
quite convincingly on
the marriage of daughters
as basically insurance
and business transactions
and so on.
So there are-- a divorce is
like a breakup and so on.
We try to measure
liquidity, and so
it's tempting to just
have everything in cash,
but actually here and in
India, grain, rice here,
and sorghum in India is
people borrow and lend in it,
they make commitments
to pay in it.
So we actually have in
kind barter transactions.
Now here again,
you could imagine--
and when I teach
monetary economics,
we get into this for sure.
The notion of liquidity is how
quickly one could sell an asset
or is there a deep
market for it.
So this is, again, both
a judgment call here
because we aggregate it
up, but also opens up
a really interesting sort of
line of research where you
can study liquidity and
transactions in these village
economies.
What to do with livestock?
What does a cow--
a cash cow-- well, so we
just separate the asset
from the income
and expense part.
So the cow is the asset.
The cow, if it's young, actually
appreciates in value over time.
You get a capital
gain out of it.
Cattle can die prematurely,
you'll get a capital loss.
We actually try to
book all those things.
Meanwhile, the cow-- the
dairy cattle up in Lopburi
are delivering milk.
So that's the revenue stream
off the asset, actually.
It's a great analogy,
like fruit off the tree.
They're not Lucas trees,
they're, I don't know,
Lopburi animals.
And gifts, as I've said--
so I don't think
I'll belabor that.
I spared you a lot.
Just want to
introduce the concept.
In the underlying
data, you'll see
a transaction, like received
wage income in cash.
Now what to do with
the answer to that?
50 baht.
Well, it enters in all three
incomes, all three statements.
Basically the cash enters an
increase in the balance sheet
as an increase in
a kind of asset,
it's revenue on the
income statement,
and it's incoming cash flow
on the statement of cash flow.
Not every transaction
in the data
enter on all three accounts.
The struggle was
deciding indeed where
to put all of these things,
although the accounting
standards double-entry
bookkeeping does provide
a discipline-- and yes,
we made mistakes initially
and things didn't add up.
So then we realized we hadn't
entered things appropriately.
That's what
double-entry bookkeeping
is, some clerk having
all the transactions
and then doing the books,
quote-unquote, consists
of entering all those daily
transactions into ledgers
and creating statements.
So these happened to all be
cash transactions, that's
kind of an accident,
it's just the first page
of about eight or 10
of them in the book,
and I'll skip the rest.
Now let's talk about
liquidity management.
Here's a statement of
cash flow, D for deficit.
So you run a deficit.
The deficit, say, is the
difference between your income
in a month--
cash revenue, I should say--
and, say, consumption--
minus consumption,
minus investment, OK?
So it's a deficit, you
had more demands for cash
than you received in cash.
Well, again, by the
construction of the accounts,
everything has to balance.
So we know exactly how
a deficit is financed.
We even try to
measure the currency.
So we have F1 through Fn
are these financing devices,
and then you can
do a little math,
basically, multiply
both sides by D,
but D is the sum of the F,
so basically you get this,
and then you square
it, and then you
divide by the different squared,
and all of a sudden you're
looking at a variance--
covariance decomposition,
which is exactly true.
So if you want to know the role
that a particular financing
device like F1 is playing
in terms of smoothing
the deficits, it's
basically like running
a regression of the deficit
onto the financing device
and getting a
regression coefficient.
It's really cute.
That you could do it
one financing device
at a time and the sum
of those coefficients
has to add up to 1.
So this isn't the only
way to talk about--
this is variance/covariance,
not order of magnitude.
If you have two devices that
track each other perfectly
but there's always a
gap, this thing will say,
it's the perfect smoother,
that's the thing that's used,
but in fact, the gap remains.
So you have to be a
little cautious about
the interpretation sometimes.
So how do you finance?
Well you could
decrease your deposits
if you have them in a financial
institution, you could--
this is an odd way to put it--
decrease in your net ROSCA
position, which means basically
you don't want to pay in,
you want to get paid out.
You want to be a recipient.
You could call in your
loans, you could borrow,
you could get gifts or
decrease your cash holdings.
And for two case
study households,
we actually measure--
and you probably unfortunately
can't see it very well,
but this cash is close to
100 or 1, basically, 100%.
These numbers, though,
are the quartiles
of the province in which this
case study household A lives.
So the median is 76%, this
guy's actually on the high side,
but still, in this
variance/covariance sense,
3/4 of the deficits is
households in Lopburi
are financing their
deficits with cash.
Cash.
They're holding
great gobs of it.
Unbelievable amounts
of it in the house.
And when they get
these adverse shocks
or they have more expenses than
inputs, it outcomes to cash.
You want to say, well why
isn't-- is it in a savings
account?
Not much.
Negligible.
Now I was a little
critical of this sort
of measuring savings accounts.
This is a measure
of savings account.
I guess at the end
of the day, the issue
is, are they managing
their cash well?
This is the starting point.
We have the
measurement, maybe they
should be putting
more of it in the bank
and taking it out
when they need it.
They don't do it much, so
that is a bit of a puzzle.
Gifts and loans are--
I think this is not--
this is out of the book
and not the latest version.
AUDIENCE: This is the latest.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Is it?
So OK.
So you can see these upper
quartiles are getting up
to 15%, 20%, 25%.
So gifts are used
by some households
substantially as well.
It's not just a
pure cash economy.
And like-- well that's
cash management.
We can talk about
asset management.
It's really the same
concept, except instead
of operating on
the cash flow, you
do this accrual notion
of accounting and look
at sort of net savings.
And I'll come back to
that later, essentially.
And the portfolio management.
So here, in answer
to the question that
was raised earlier, is
looking at something
like profits over assets,
which is a return on assets,
and then creating 10
different measurements of it.
Do you want to exclude household
consumption of their own output
and not count it into income?
We counted total utility
expenses as a business expense,
maybe we shouldn't
have done that.
Maybe it was a household
expense for, quote,
consumption purposes.
So service flow
from fixed assets,
which would be very natural
to do for durable goods,
we tried that.
We could take income but
then add gifts and transfers
even though it's
really not associated
with a project, and
especially this sort of cash.
So it turned out
that this distinction
of cash versus accrual
was very important.
The treatment of gifts
And up here, which where I
didn't start, but I could,
is in trying to get at the
cost of household labor--
own household labor
used in production,
that is a monster difficulty,
because you don't see for many
of them what they would have
earned as wages in someone
else's farm and so on, yet it's
clear that's very important
and it makes a very
big difference.
So hopefully knowing
that, one can bend over
backwards to try to get a
better sense of the opportunity
cost of labor.
So as I said, let's look
at some uses of these.
This is a paper with Anan
on the wealth distribution,
and let's look at that 1%.
Let's go get 'em.
Let's get the top 1%.
How much wealth does
the top 1% have?
It's huge.
They start out in 1999 with
about 35% of the total wealth.
Now it's actually diminished.
This is the-- frankly,
a wonderful thing
to have all these many,
many years of data.
It's diminished to 26%.
What's going on is this
stuff at the bottom end
where the bottom 50%
have 5% of the wealth.
By the way, this is typical of
the US and European history,
and it's very skewed
wealth distributions.
But this thing actually
doubles over the space
of about 12 years here.
AUDIENCE: Is this
including cash?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it
could be like cash.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It could be.
There was a question.
AUDIENCE: Oh yes.
Not related to this, but what
household characteristics does
[INAUDIBLE] economic ones like
[INAUDIBLE] household members--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, we have all
of that, all the demography.
Age, education.
Yeah.
So in answer to your
question, we'll see what the--
that among some of
these poor people,
they have a very high return on
assets, real physical assets,
and we'll see where they're
putting their money.
So inequalities going
down in some sense, right?
So anyway, this is not the
story of a poverty trap.
Now I'm not claiming
this is universal truth,
I'm not claiming there
aren't poverty traps, really,
and models and in
the real world.
Many countries still have--
like India-- vast
populations of poor people,
but maybe be a little leery
that at least in the case
of Thailand, you think about
starting at a low level--
and some of these guys
remain in poverty,
but there is a huge
growth dynamic going on.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And how
much is the very--
in terms of the actual
distribution of income,
how much of the very
rich got surveyed?
How much-- of this--
the people who got
surveyed, were they
like a top truncated
distribution,
like their very interested
and you know, the ones
who answered this survey.
It's usual--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, it's--
well, it's a stratified
random sample.
In some cases we actually
ended up with everybody
in the village, but maybe
only two out of the 16 or so
villages did that happen.
I think it's more
typical that we're
worried the rich guys are
hiding some of their assets
rather than them not
responding at all.
I could not run these
surveys on my own,
I have built up close
friendships and collaborators
in Thailand who are amazingly
good at getting households
to participate, and there
are occasional scares where
they think the government's
going to start taxing them,
the chicken farmers were making
great gobs of money in profits,
and rumors circulated that they
better conceal their wealth.
They dropped out, but we
got almost all of them
back in after a while.
AUDIENCE: So I told them that
attrition is very low, but what
about the initial response rate?
What is that?
Close to 100%?
Like when you
actually went in and--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
It was very high.
AUDIENCE: What do they get
for answering the survey?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: I think
Harry mentioned
that people get gifts for--
AUDIENCE: No, it's
not substantial.
It's just like you
get a new year's gift.
So it's not worth the time.
So they don't like look
at it from a financial--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We
give them a bottle
of fish sauce or a
blanket, or something,
and that's a Thai
sort of cultural thing
to establish goodwill and
that you care about a person.
We just did not
and we deliberately
avoided getting into the
business of paying people.
Because for one thing, then
other households in the village
feel like they're getting
cheated and it's just-- it's--
So this is all
voluntary participation.
13 years of households
answering questions
monthly with only, whatever
it is, 2% per year dropping.
So here is-- there's a
movie called Falling Down--
I don't even remember
that guy went berserko
with a machine gun.
I always think of that.
So not everybody's
wealth is going up,
and in fact, some
people actually
find their wealth is falling.
So we can track
their net position
in the distribution of
wealth, and here, you
can see these
people climbing up,
and other people,
quote, falling down.
This is the histogram of
sort of in percentiles.
By the way, the average
has to be 0 because it's--
the net change is 0
over all the households,
but you can see
some substantial--
1 standard deviation is
like 14 percentage points.
AUDIENCE: So do you have any
[INAUDIBLE] falling down?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So I guess one thing that sort
of got lost in the shuffle
because we didn't decide
clearly whether it would show
within the TA session or
I would show it here is
kind of a life cycle picture.
So we've created
by cohorts, by age.
And you can see, especially
in the areas near Bangkok,
a classic life cycle.
So as these
households are young,
they start to accumulate
wealth, but after a while,
especially as their
income falls off,
they start running
down their assets.
So this does not
distinguish by age.
So it's a bit misleading,
it's not like there's some--
necessarily some young household
that's just consistently eating
more than their income.
There are households like that,
and that raises this issue
before of what's going on.
I mean, if the husband
isn't there, for example,
and the wife is running
some hair salon,
she's consistently eating more
than then the household income,
but you kind of wonder if
there isn't something going on,
and we just don't
have the husband there
who chooses either for
personal or occupation reasons
to be in Bangkok the whole time.
So then we get a
misleading picture
that she may be in trouble or
she may know more the future
than we do.
So let's do a simple
decomposition.
Here's savings.
Savings on both sides
in absolute amount.
And then divide and
multiply by profits
from the household and
businesses, all of them
summed up, and divide
and multiply by assets.
So that has to be true.
It's an identity.
But savings over
basically profits
is a savings rate out of
income, and profits over assets
is the return on
assets post-multiplied
by the level of assets.
So basically you can look at--
you can look at the
change in wealth
or the percentage change in
wealth, and wealth comes--
where is a change in
wealth coming from?
It's coming from savings
plus income and gifts.
The savings thing is
decomposed up here.
So part of the mechanical
accounting drivers
of increasing wealth has
to do with savings rates
and rates of return on assets.
And maybe gifts if
they're important.
So here is the
correlation of the growth
of net worth with savings
rates, and depending
on whether the
unit of observation
is household month or household
year or households averaged up
over all of the months
and years of the data,
you do see some positive
significant correlations.
So in fact, not
too surprisingly,
some of the increase
in net worth
is coming from households
who have high savings rates.
But the bigger part of the
story is the correlation
with the return on assets.
And there, it's consistent
pretty much at all levels.
So household by household
with our measurement,
we look at their productivity
in terms of rate of return,
and then see whether their net
wealth is going up or down,
and it's the households who
have high rates of return who
have the high--
highest rates of increase
in their net worth.
And it's quite persistent.
Here, we look at return on
assets in the first half
and second half of the sample
at the time that we did it.
So if they were identical, they
would lie on a 45-degree line,
and these scatter points are
close with one exception, which
is Buriram.
Oh, you should be thinking
models at this point.
Remember the productivity,
the TFP thing?
That's the thing sitting outside
multiplicatively in front
of the production function?
These are household-specific
TFP numbers sort of.
It's not a very sophisticated--
production function
is just linear.
So it's not really just--
you'd rather have like the
marginal product of capital
and pre-multiply, this is a
linear production function.
The marginal product
is just the average.
But it's very persistent.
So in these models, the issue
is, are those TFP shocks IID
over households,
are they the same
unless you get blasted
with some shock?
And this suggests that
the household level
it's really quite persistent.
Buriram is an
interesting exception,
and I'll just say
it in words, there
are many more occupations
shifts in Buriram
than in the other
three provinces.
It turns out these villages
aren't really villages anymore,
they've paved over our
soil moisture readers
and they become
part of the town.
There's a big construction
boom going on.
Part of that is
pararubber, part of it
is Scandinavian tourists
coming in marrying Thai women
and staying.
The place is just like
a construction boom.
So people shifted
from rice-growing
or money-lending or
other things to laying
tile and all these
things, and they
had a higher return
on their assets
as a result on average
of those switches.
So that's kind of reassuring.
It's another sense
in which households
are aware of their success.
And here, coming back
to Witt's question,
if you partition
into low, medium,
and high return on
assets and looked
at what they did with
their increasing wealth,
these high ROA guys are putting
money back in the business.
They're buying equipment,
they're investing and putting
it into their business.
And that's not true of
the medium or low guys.
These guys are doing
the financial assets.
So more of their
increasing financial wealth
is potentially in cash, but to
the extent that we measured ROA
accurately, which
we have tried very
hard to do in all kinds of
different ways, we're getting
the reinforcing message
here that we've measured it
accurately because they seem
to do what you would think,
which is, you're not going to
put your money in a savings
account when you've got
a really high return.
And later in another lecture
will try to adjust for risk.
So now we'll aggregate
it up to villages
and use those same
financial accounts.
We do have to struggle
again with this dual role
that households play as
consumers and producers.
So much of economics
is driven by here
is firms maximizing profits,
here is households maximizing
utility-- these are
households running businesses,
so what are we going to do?
And in particular, what are
we going to do with the labor?
Well, we made a decision,
although here, we do
check and do robustness checks.
And what I'm going
to show you today
is treating even the
labor income as something
like consulting income, like
they're providing a service--
their business is
to provide a labor
service to other households,
and they get profits from that.
Now if you think about a
production sector and aggregate
up, to the extent that inputs
from one business are--
the outputs from one business
are an input to the other,
the net is zero and
it doesn't count.
But in these villages,
the output of one business
could be someone
else's consumption,
and it doesn't net out.
Both get measured.
As it would if you're
distinguishing households
from firms.
We can actually measure and
ask about the transactions.
So we know the transaction
partners almost.
We did screw up with
consumption because we
forgot to ask
consistently where they
buy stuff, which has to do with
the price thing also mentioned
earlier.
But fortunately,
and I'm sure you'll
be more than happy to
take my word for it,
there is an accounting identity,
so you can kind of back up
as a residual how much of
that output is basically
sold and consumed in the village
because we measured everything
else.
In other words, on
the buying side,
we don't see it, but-- because
we don't know where they bought
it, but we actually figured
out on the selling side
that it came from somebody who
produced it in the village.
Measurement error,
you asked-- somebody
asked about the rich
guys not participating.
If a moneylender were
like the central node
and the money lender refused
to answer our questions,
we're going to get
really screwed up
in terms of the flow of funds
and the balance of payments
and everything else.
Because we are going to act
like the average overall--
the households in the
village is the representation
of what's going on in the
village itself as a whole.
To the extent that
there's measurement error
but there is IID
over households,
and to the extent that we
have a lot of households,
then hopefully that
helps make the case
that we've got a
reasonably good measure.
So how do you create
these accounts?
What is GNP anyway?
GDP?
Everyone seems to be
obsessed about it.
OK, it just comes from
the income statement.
So basically, here's
a statement of income,
it's what you would expect.
You've got revenues come from
production, or for that matter,
if you're a lender or
saver from interest,
you've got capital gains.
You subtract off
capital losses, maybe
you have sort of a paid payment
from an insurance indemnity.
So those are revenues,
here is basically expenses,
production expenses,
interest expenses
on loans, depreciation,
insurance premia, taxes, et
cetera.
So net income before tax--
before income tax but
after property tax
is what makes these things
balance because this
is basically the profit--
it's basically
revenues less expenses.
So that should be
comfortable, sound sort of
reassuringly familiar.
All that we do is
basically take this stuff
and subtract it off
from both sides.
That cancels it out
on the right-hand side
and puts it on the
left-hand side.
So basically you have production
revenue less production
expenses, and that's
basically the rest
is equal to the payments
to factors of production.
So you're paying
stuff out in interest,
you're paying out in taxes,
depreciation is over here,
and you're paying out to
the owners of the enterprise
namely profits.
So you may remember
vaguely that there's
two ways to measure
income on the output side
and on the factor payment side,
and they add up to each other.
So this is
value-added, basically.
The only catch here is
the way we treated labor,
you don't see a labor
expense over here,
because normally
value-added, you're
only subtracting off
intermediate inputs
and other purchased inputs,
but here, we actually subtract
off the labor because of
the way we conceptualize
that problem or that issue.
So you want to see what's
happening over time in the four
provinces, four villages
per province, Chachoengsao
GDP or really village product is
going down pretty consistently.
Now what happened is the
shrimp ponds, basically,
people had
converted-- yeah, that
stuff you're buying
in Costco or Walmart,
those are typically Thai shrimp.
But the ponds-- so
there's some disease.
And so-- and household,
some of them switched.
And the fish and others
now are actually,
with the world grain prices
being relatively high,
they're refilling in the
ponds and planting rice again.
AUDIENCE: Rob?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes?
AUDIENCE: What are the different
colored lines [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Each
of four villages.
So--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
[INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So you
can see, is every village
like every other village?
Well, to some degree, yes,
but the levels are different,
and sometimes even the movements
over time are a bit different.
Another thing to watch
out for is the scale here,
because in order to clearly
display each village--
each of the four villages in
a province, where changing
the scale of a province.
Sisaket is a lot poorer than--
even in their worst days,
Chachoengsao villages
are better off
substantially than Sisaket.
So the income levels
are maybe on average
three times higher
in Chachoengsao.
They're almost ordered by
their distance to Bangkok.
I won't bore you with this.
This is just to
what do households
do with their profits?
And then the story is mostly
in the northeast. they eat it.
And in central region, they're
more likely to put it back
in the business or their
farm as retained earnings.
Savings investment
account, that's
probably worth looking at.
Here's the balance sheet.
So remember, we had assets
and liabilities and net worth.
This is the change over
time in the balance sheet.
So it's like a
first-time difference.
So changes in liabilities
and changes in net worth
must equal to the change
in all the assets,
especially if you include
change in net worth over there.
These could be
financial or real.
Well hopefully this is
comfortable and familiar.
Just the notion of having assets
and liabilities and net worth
and taking a time difference.
What is the savings
investment account?
Well, you just basically take
the change in liabilities
and put it on the
left-hand side.
That leaves the change in net
worth on the right-hand side,
and then what you do with
it on the left-hand side.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So before we were
talking about household gifts
equity.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So does that
mean that they get
counted as financial assets?
Where would gifts
in a village enter?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Contributed capital.
AUDIENCE: Contributed capital.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
That's what we called it.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Cool.
Thanks.
I'm sorry, it just occurred to--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
No, no, it's fine.
AUDIENCE: --no idea
where they're going.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, yeah.
It's there, because if
they're getting gifts and not
eating too much, it should
increase their wealth,
and therefore, it should show
up somewhere as either reduced
debt or increased assets.
And that phenomenon depends
a lot on where you are.
AUDIENCE: But entered
both sides, right?
It entered as increased cash,
and then also increased--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well--
AUDIENCE: --contributed capital.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
The concept is here.
So basically say
this is positive,
and your change in
net worth is positive
because either retained
earnings or contributed capital.
And then the issue is
portfolio management,
it's what did you do with it?
And you could put it in cash,
that's in financial assets,
but you could also have it in
inventory as I was alluding to,
or have livestock assets
or other fixed assets.
So it's worthy of
study to figure out
what they're doing with it.
AUDIENCE: And
sometimes the idea is
there's a reciprocity,
and the gift that I
give to my buddy in
the next village is
in some sense a residual--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So yeah.
AUDIENCE: So yea, I
guess that's what--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I mean,
the extreme versions of that
would be the kids
that go off to Bangkok
and they send money back.
Now can you distinguish
they're just
caring about their parents?
And there's a very strong
Thai tradition there.
But then eventually they
come back and run the farm.
But it is-- it's a
real incoming flow,
so we have to do
something with it.
We could just not call
it equity or something,
and in effect, that's
what we're doing here,
is just keeping track of it
separately as a line item.
OK.
So I guess I said this before.
Oh, by the way, on the
lifecycle diagrams,
it's really dramatic
that in the northeast,
wealth isn't dropping
as these guys get older,
and likewise, they're
not accumulating
a lot of financial or real
assets as they're young
and getting older either.
There doesn't seem to
be this life cycle,
and the gifts just
get bigger and bigger.
You don't have to get
older to get those gifts.
It's the huge--
I think it's overlapping
generations, essentially.
It's really quite different
between the northeast
and the central area,
and that's related,
because it's kind
of showing up here.
So then we get to the
balance of payments.
So basically, villages trade.
They produce stuff and
sell it and they buy stuff
as inputs and by consumption.
So we got sort of a trade
balance that we measure.
You could add in interest
earnings from, quote, abroad,
but it's really mostly
from the same country.
They're getting interest
on savings accounts
that they held outside the
village or in those gifts
again.
So you may or may
not have seen this,
this gets really
kind of confusing
the way the standard
accounting is done.
Trade balance plus this other
earnings on gifts and interest
is called the current
account, and then you
have the current
account balanced
with the financial count
and the capital account.
But they didn't
write current account
equal financial account,
so this stuff has
to be-- if you're trading
a lot, like China,
and you have a big sort
of current account,
this stuff has to be negative.
A negative in the
financial account
is actually, quote, a
good thing in the sense
that you're accumulating assets.
But believe me, it'll
throw you every time when
you start thinking about it.
And then I won't
drive this for you,
but it turns out that
if you take this sort
of Keynesian-looking
thing, which is really just
an accounting statement,
income less consumption less
investment plus transfers--
that's not taxes--
has to be identically
equal to the trade balance
plus sort of capital
account balance, which
we keep track of separately,
plus the change in inventories.
So largely, if they
run an export surplus,
they're going to save
it, but not quite.
Because they have
other ways of saving,
you have to adjust for
changes in the capital,
buying and selling with
foreigners, so to speak,
and the changes in inventory.
AUDIENCE: So the left-hand
side is a financial account
in this case?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
It's not obvious
how you get from this to this.
And I decided not to
try to derive it today.
But it is an identity.
One follows from the other.
And here, the
balance of payments
accounts for these
villages, mostly
this story is they're
running surpluses.
The trade or trade and
current account is this blue
or blue-red stuff, and--
although here you
see a difference.
Chachoengsao's
getting in trouble,
its balance of payments
is going down in the sense
that it's running less
and less of a surplus.
Whereas Lopburi is
the other story.
It's always increasing.
The difference
between red and blue
is basically the gifts that play
a big role in the northeast.
And here's an instance
of Buriram coming off
the financial crisis,
which was 1997-98,
but anyway, they actually ran
a balance of payments deficit.
So this opens up the whole
vista of international economics
and what's going on
using those kinds of ways
of conceptualizing the problem.
And just to remind you, because
I promised an application
for each section, we've
had tons of models
of the role of financing
constraints or other obstacles
in growth and TFP and
so on and so forth.
So here's just some model with
arch where we do the following.
We take these villages to
be small open economies,
we see a drop in
the interest rate--
it's actually true worldwide--
and we see the
number of new loans
increasing this has to do in
part with this village fund
stuff that we'll talk about
later the Million Baht
Fund in Thailand.
This is the collateral
constraint--
this is a model thing.
So we're going to act as if that
innovation associated with more
loans was like a weakening
of the borrowing constraint
and feed it into
a model, and it's
a trade model with
financial underpinnings,
and it predicts things like the
relative price of agriculture
relative to manufactured goods.
In the model and in the
data, we're kind of close.
And a real goal was to try
to get the wages right,
and here is the actual and
model-driven real wages.
Why is this a struggle?
If you think about
Heckscher-Ohlin,
that has to do with
the area around Bangkok
being very capital-intensive
and not having so much labor,
so interest rates are
lower and wages are higher;
in the northeast, it's the
other way around because capital
and wealth is relatively low.
So you think that
over time you're
going to get
convergence, which means
wages ought to be dropping
in the central area,
and they're not.
So then you introduce
this financial constraint,
and you get the
dynamics that have
to do with choosing
occupations and so on.
So that hopefully you remember
enough from the other papers
that we covered to kind of
imagine how one would fill this
out, and we're actually at
these calibrated values--
we're actually
matching quite well
all the income shares for wages,
manufacturing, and agriculture.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: I might
remember wrong, but just--
yeah, it's very likely,
but in your paper
with Kaboski on the Million--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Baht Fund, yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it
the interest rate
wasn't going to be with
the intervention, was it?
Now you just said that
the interest rate drop has
to do with the Million Baht--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Remember, what we're doing
is kind of a variation
in the cross-section
as a function of the percentage
of households in the village.
So the per-capita
treatment is we're
seeing whether that has any
impact on the interest rate.
What I showed you was the time
variation in the interest rate,
so it's a very different object.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So that's kind of like
differenced out, basically.
It's the relative
difference from the trend
and whether the
Million Baht Fund
had something to do with it.
OK.
The last thing is flow of funds.
These are the flow of funds
accounts for Thailand,
basically.
A quick introduction
to flow of funds,
you've got non-financial
corporations,
financial corporations,
government, households,
and not-for-profit corporations,
and the rest of the world.
Those are the sectors.
And then you have
acquisition of assets,
and they're actually in
detailed financial accounts.
When the flow of funds
accounts-- when they exist,
you've got money and
gold and currency,
securities, loans, and so on.
So acquiring a loan means
basically you're a lender.
On the other hand, you've
got sort of liabilities
down here, and so that you can
have a loan which represents
an increase in borrowing.
It takes a lot of concentration
to constantly remember
uses means putting money--
so the idea is you run--
you have positive savings,
where do you put your money?
And you could put it
here or you could reduce
your deficits, or if you--
reduce your liabilities.
If you run it the
other way and you
have negative
savings or something,
and then you've got to
increase your liabilities
or run down and sell off
some assets that you own.
These are the
traditional labor labels
in the flow of funds by sector.
Is there a relationship
between flow
of funds and the
national income accounts?
Yes.
Actually, in principle,
they should all
be consistent with one another.
But they're often not.
The thing that is most
consistent is flow of funds
into and out of the
financial institutions
because commercial banks and
other financial corporations
are required to
report to regulators,
and the central bank
keeps track of things.
So we see most accurately
deposits coming in,
loans going out for
financial corporations.
We often see little or
anything of the transactions
between the other sectors.
There are national
income and product
account for those sectors,
and we see, therefore, savings
for those, but those
savings numbers
are often radically
different from the savings
we would impute from
just seeing transactions
with the measured
formal financial sector.
Another way to say
this, if you read Deaton
and so on, the savings you see
coming from household surveys
gives you very, very different
numbers than the savings
you'll see at the level of
the national income accounts,
and that's because the
measurement is missing,
so households get treated as the
residual in the national income
accounts.
But flow of funds data do
exist, and to some extent,
they can be created, and
Thailand is, for example--
and Mexico-- creating improved
financial flow of funds
accounts.
I'd like to think we had
something to do with that.
We can also do it at
the village level.
I've shown you a lot, but
let me just jump here.
At the national
aggregate level, these
are the traditional sectors,
and here's a diamond,
and basically you can see
from the standpoint of banks,
households are
interior-- basically
investing in banks,
but that's a liability
for the banking sector.
Savings accounts
are to be paid back.
On the other hand, in this
period between '08 and--
'04 and '08, you know the
banking sector was investing
in the rest of the world and
that had to do with Thailand
running a balance
of payments surplus.
But this is at
the village level.
And here, you can distinguish
financial corporations,
transactions with businesses
outside the village,
transactions of the village
funds we just talked about,
and you can see them using
currency, running surpluses
or deficits with these
other entities in terms
of the objects.
So the point here is that
it's a common way of measuring
and it doesn't just have to be
applied as it is conventionally
at the national level.
Flow of funds can zoom
in and zoom out by region
and tell you which object's
moving around over time.
And in fact, you can read
it in a little more leisure
style on your own, there's
papers of Guerrieri and Guido
Lorenzoni and Monika Piazzesi
and Martin Schneider,
and these are,
granted, about the US,
but it's basically looking
at the household sector
and going to the flow
of funds data in the US
to measure changes in
savings and borrowing.
And this same
language that they use
to try to understand
what happens
in a financial crisis
when all of a sudden you
can't borrow as much
because the banks are tight,
or in Monika's case, what
happens when there are many,
many more young people
entering and they have
certain expectations
about inflation,
and each one of these
pairs of authors
is doing this kind of experiment
in the context of a model.
So these very same
models that rely
on a sort of macro-aggregate
looking, though,
at sectors in the US also
apply to developing countries.
In fact Guido's model is eerily
similar, although none of us
recognized it at the time, to
the model that Joe and I used
to analyze the village
fund in in Thailand.